[Music]
[Applause]
bringing brandle shamble Golf Channel
lead Studio analyst the level of
surprise when you heard that John ROM
was defecting to the live
tour uh not high at all I mean the
rumors have been rampant for a couple of
weeks uh so if you go by the rumors not
at all but if you go by his comments
what over the last year and a half or so
where he was
where he was adamant that uh he wouldn't
leave for live that he had pledged his
fty to the PGA Tour and said it wouldn't
even be smart thing for him to do at
this point in his career I'd say there
are a lot of people that were surprised
that weren't uh keeping up with the
rumors as of late why is the Liv tour
still acquiring golfers and somebody for
$500
million I guess after the proposed
merger and the wording in it that U uh
didn't allow them to recruit players or
poach from either side by both parties
uh the Department of Justice their
Anti-Trust division were they were
concerned about the wording in it and uh
so both parties got rid of that wording
which opened the door but really I think
the reason Liv did this was it was more
reminder the PGA Tour who was recruiting
private Equity over the last couple of
months and that was well known I think
more than anything it was just a
reminder to the PGA tour of who really
still had the hammer uh you know lives
in the in the more dominant position
here they've got $32 trillion worth of
oil underneath that sand and they're not
going anywhere I've said before after
the initial merger and I tried to get my
arms around it
Dan you know once once I I got to a
point where I thought I understood it
well enough I thought and I said this
that this that the second worst thing
that could happen to the PGA Tour was
this was was if this merger went through
and the worst thing that could happen to
the PGA Tour was if this merger didn't
go through oh boy yeah well I'm I'm
wondering if John ROM got to the point
where it's like um all right there might
be a merger they're going to pay me $500
million or whatever the PGA Tour kind of
went behind our back to try to do this
merger I I was a good soldier with Rory
and fought for the PGA Tour and now I
can't turn down this money and body else
has kind of taken the slings and arrows
before him that he can sort of go there
and but I mean does that sound logical
in your mind absolutely uh I I think the
whole well not the whole but a lot of
the professional golf world is kind of
got something like the Stockholm
syndrome uh with with Liv now and I
think it can go right back he pointed to
the absolute right spot after that June
6th proposed merger uh I feel like a lot
of people that were defending the PGA
Tour thinking they were on the right
side of it uh changed their position
they felt like they had been betrayed
they lost trust in the PGA Tour Zack
Johnson the captain of the Ryder Cup
team even picked Brooks Kea who had not
qualified uh for the Ryder Cup uh to be
on the Ryder Cup team so I think sort of
the trickle down theory of the PGA Tour
seemed to be doing business with people
that they had previously harshly CR
criticized open the door to everybody to
make a move something like this what is
golf going to look like what's the PGA
Tour going to look like in two
years three
years well I hope the lived deal goes
through now uh it it's it's obvious the
best thing for the PGA Tour and if it
goes through it remains to be seen
whether live lives or not uh if it
doesn't it it looks like Rah was the
strategic play that Liv needed to make
to bring this merger together because
each side has something the other side
wants uh obviously the PGA Tour would
like an infusion of money but Liv looks
at the PGA Tour and what they see is a
seat at the table
legitimacy uh Legacy uh every every one
of the 50 million golfers in the
world uh knows about the history of the
PGA Tour uh they have the respect and
recognition of commercial entities broad
commercial entities whereas there's a
lot of push back for Saudi Arabia
involvement in some of those Avenues so
Saudi Arabia gets an immediate seat at
the table and the respect and
recognition of partnering with uh uh the
single best golf entity in the world so
they both have something that they want
so if it if it comes together I think
golf is better off if it doesn't then
you're going to have this NeverEnding
competition between live and the PGA
Tour which you know sadly it's hard to
imagine how Liv loses here the governor
of Liv is yaser alayan who is well
educated very clever uh very charming
and can be quite intimidating and he
loves
golf talking to brandle shamble Golf
Channel lead Studio analyst uh if you
had a camera on Roy mroy yesterday when
he heard the news what do you think it
would have looked like or sounded like
he probably shook his head uh you know
but I listened to Roy's remarks
yesterday and I thought they were they
were spoton uh you know he he said he's
going to miss competing against uh John
ROM he said that you know he's immensely
talented all those things you know no
doubt are true I'm going to miss
watching John ROM play uh but I heard I
heard people and I read people who said
that this was devastating to the PGA
Tour I think that's hyperbole uh it
would be devastating if tiger went to
live it would be devastating if Rory
went to live it'd be devastating if
Jordan spe went to live I just listened
to the poll question answered by your
audience uh 80 88% not really interested
in Ram going to live the fact is there
are very few golfers in the world that
move the needle and compel people to buy
a ticket just to go see them very
through very few you ask the executives
that run golf around the world and it is
Tiger Rory and Jordan Speed before Phil
left it was Phil but there's Brooks kka
there's DJ there's Phil there's camon
Smith all of those Stars didn't compel
or galvanized audiences to watch live
last year so I I I agree with your
audience 88% of your audience I don't
think Rob's going to have uh a huge
impact on galvanized people to watch a
product that is inferior yeah why don't
they play four four rounds I mean that's
stupid Dan why don't they play four
rounds why don't they have a qualifying
School a theater tour uh why don't they
have a cut yeah uh all of those things
would give more legitimacy to the events
absolutely than them buying these
Stars absolutely they would have the
best players you know for the for the
PGA Tour to compete with Liv they would
have to bring in private Equity this is
the pickle they're in because they'd
have to bring in private Equity to lock
up players sign them to contracts but
private Equity unlike the Saudis would
want to make a profit so they wouldn't
sign these players for these huge
contracts the Saudis are playing the
long game and they're trying to
diversify their economy and they're
looking several decades down the road
where they absolutely are desperate to
diversify their economy so they'll lose
in the early goings of this to gain in
the long term private Equity is never
going to make a deal like that so
live upper hand hand here in the
negotiations Before I Let You Go this uh
roll back with the golf ball I was
watching the uh DP World Golf Tour and
there was an amateur who hit a drive 410
yards and there was downhill but
everybody else was hitting like 343 he's
still hit at 60 yards past everybody 5%
doesn't mean anything to these players
5% means something to me if you want to
really make an impact roll that ball
back 20% and then maybe
maybe they get back to playing these
golf courses the way they're meant to be
played your
thoughts well you know the number of
professional golfers in the world is
10,000 roughly speaking there's 50
million golfers that that equates to
0.003% of the golfers that play the game
at the highest level and a very small
percentage of them hit at 300 plus yards
certainly they don't carry it the
average carry on the PGA tour this year
was 284 yards so the USGA and the RNA
are making a decision that will hurt 98
99% of the golfers in that they will
have to absorb the cost of the R&D of
this new golf ball uh professional
golfers don't pay for golf balls and and
they will to your point Dan they will so
quickly recoup this lost distance of
this golf ball they'll they'll do it
like that they will literally do it like
that you look at the distance gauge huge
distance gauge that padrick Harrington
made it 49 years old Phil Nicholson made
it 49 years old Stuart Zink made it 49
years old Cameron Tali made and scores
of others you look at those huge
distance gains and they will be
compelled to do that meanwhile you me we
will all lose five 10 yards or so on
every t- shot and almost every single
approach shot yeah I didn't have that
five or 10 to lose brandle I didn't
either I didn't either I can hear my
balls land almost now
uh great to talk to you again and uh
thanks for joining us Bud always a
pleasure Dan take care brandle shambling
Golf Channel lead Studio analyst